can you imagine sizing somebody up and
being like oh they're toxic they're no
good I'm not not a good person let's
just hit it and run
this is what I'm talking about about
women now like trying so hard to copy
what was once thought of as like bad
male Behavior
I I'm like thinking back to my high
school
I can think of maybe two girls that were
like this and they were ostracized by
men
I'm not saying that certain guys
wouldn't sleep with them but no one took
them seriously talking like this now
this is the dating pool
you'll go out and you gotta hear
somebody be like oh yeah let's just get
it over with
no wonder there's erectile dysfunction
I'm not lying that's not sexy that is
not sex that's nasty I'm not saying that
guys won't be able to hit it and walk
but even they are thinking um who's she
gonna wind up talking like that